objective baker you've taken it
[Music]
that subjective dog lost
good morning good morning Eric oh sorry
it's okay I'm now awake welcome we're
early today on gamespot live work early
like couple hours cuz we wanted to check
out battlefield 5 closed alpha round two
technically we're a little late cuz I
think it came out like at 1:00 a.m. but
there was no way in hell we were coming
in at 1:00 a.m. so yeah here we are way
in hell Rob's Rob's on the keyboard
mouse and then controller when he's
flying and when in no way switch that
game that's the only way to fly my
opinion with a controller let me try to
bring up some of the changes you need
more audio are you good
um I could use a little more the changes
yeah I would like to hear them I think I
think ultimately the changes with this
alpha are I guess the bigger ones are
that oh god I was running good morning
the biggest changes I know of are
ass okay let's do this all again changes
I know of are they did some some
tinkering with progression and they also
did got-dang it one other thing that was
actually bigger than that I see a lot of
changes to damage so yeah so some vowels
in there there's one other thing if you
keep going sorry all the way down I
don't know there's one other thing I
can't remember now progression and
something else I'm it's good morning I
let me take a look in the first color
mingles get an idea of how fast players
scored points in the time it took for
them to level up through the ranks
respond this we have done some changes
that will better cater to players across
all play styles and skill level we have
also made improvements to matchmaking
and fixed issues related to quad
functionality squad functionality we
hope that these changes will get you and
your squad faster into battlefield and
then there's a bunch of weapon changes
that I could go through or I could just
link this in the chat because there's
just too many I'll let you guys read
that yourself if you're curious about
weapon changes first kill the day good
morning
I'm using the the give ale this is the
medic class okay so this is the weapon
that we likes from last time we played
oh wow the is it the gear 43 that's
right okay decreased max range from 26.5
15 meters almost cut in half there
increased damage fall-off range from
51.52 60 meters decreased minimum damage
from 36 to 34 Bryce yeah I have yet to
see that guy kill you
I guess he moved out of the way after
the fact
anyone the major changes as mentioned
better squad support or joining up of
squads and then also just progression
and then there's you know the weapon
changes are all just like balance yeah
they had some they had some fairly big
bugs lasts closed alpha or like you
couldn't even join into your slaw like
or pick us a different squad oh there's
a tank here you don't see this they do
now
got um got him from way downtown
well maybe not well they're kind of
flanking us here well you're on Baker
Bravo
show yourself I think you showed
yourself
oh so close no man I should be hanging
with my squad here yeah you should be
yeah giving all those health packs to
them that you're not that sweet
two-piece special the two-piece the
two-piece the twofer it was on buy one
get one free buy one get one free a nice
guys you're the medic Wow
there's not a chance I wouldn't survive
of that rush there I'm ed says this map
does just doesn't give me the world war
two feels it should be more gloomy
gloomy wouldn't you want a filter wants
it to be darker probably well they have
so they have naive aerations in the
other mode the grand operations it's
that we don't have another map you don't
know like over time a map will get added
I know during cod beta this weekend they
added Hacienda like not the first day
second a9 there are so many dudes coming
you got it yeah stab him stab them with
your yeah I'm getting my hotkeys figured
out here still oh I want Oh what where
was that
who are you just still doing that thing
where the buildings at least this time
you can see the fire Oh interesting okay
do you play fortnight umm we do from
time to time we should do it every week
but now I kind of let the ruk team
handle it so they do our challenges
every week yes no different map yeah for
now maybe maybe like I said maybe as we
get into it it's possible but you never
know oh come on sorry I'm yelling this
is hot Mike feather'd your alpha key
please unfortunately don't have keys to
give away what's up Eric
how you doing and this coffee is like
super strong I was all excited because
my fiancee brought coffee back from New
Orleans
congratulations Eric thank you this is
everyone everyone should comment on that
Eric Eric is getting married
congratulations there that's not till
next year
yeah but yeah this coffee is like super
strong like super strong I have to get
used to it so Raymond Carter asks how do
you get beta beta is looking like I
think is it like a pre by September I
think there's an exclusive for Xbox one
but beta is not active right now this is
closed alpha so you would you you're
flying I don't know this guy's is there
being that church I don't I don't think
I don't know I don't know if there is a
bayonet on any these weapons that so
that was in battlefield one if that's
what the person is referring to at least
if they brought that over I mean maybe
put ball r17 we do giveaways but not
always keys
sometimes we do though like we gave away
cod keys last week caught up visit our
beta beta prime e fritz
basically the two big changes as Rob had
mentioned earlier is how progression
works and then also who is good yes das
is good it's okay so here was that okay
so some of the buildings I recall from
the last alpha I was burning even though
I didn't see the fire and I don't know
if that was the case here yeah that
happened a couple times huh winning the
battle royale out well I don't have no
idea for battlefield it's called it
royale right didn't even call it yeah
they it it was kind of implied that
they're like big panel event that it was
gonna be a later edition in the year
like I would expect that in maybe even
December like that I don't I don't I
don't think there's on release yeah I
don't think they were they were pushing
it to be a launch at least okay well if
we were talking about cod still pods
Battle Royale is September the data for
it I think that's what a lot of people
are curious about myself included like I
just have no idea what that's gonna be
like could be good
who knows I'm excited for it how do you
feel about I mean that's a it's too far
away from battlefield but like how did
you feel about the cod shooting oh it's
good I liked it you know like it's
definitely
still hard as I've aged my twitch
reactions aren't as good as they used to
be but I may be mad that guy if you're
if you get there fast enough
yeah there's gonna be so many guys here
backing yeah but you're medic you're
right get the other guy first Allah too
late
yeah your backup patch yourself up so um
let's go chat kind of clean here so I'm
gonna really don't need the negativity
here people we should be promoting
positive stream positive positivity in
the stream what does that mean
someone was just saying that like I
don't actually want to say it actually I
don't know why you asked me to then
trigger me to almost say it but I'm
definitely just not gonna say it it's
like he's getting hit and like you look
at wailed and died but then you had to
shoot oh this is such a good spot yeah
someone else is gonna see me though
alright squad wait it's going to weigh a
bit no I don't think that's how it's
been some people asked like do you miss
like a more modern battlefield nope no
you like this cuz I know last year was
like a big deal you know
battlefield 2 going back to like the
world war the world wars yeah and and
then same with with Cod but you know
obviously Cod swapped it and went back
to that total future I guess yeah just
like a pro lot it's like a prologue to
like what black ops 3 anyway yeah but
like even if like you know like they're
not doing any kind of narrative on that
there it's just a younger prophet and
like yeah younger ruin and all that
because they don't have to write there's
no there's no pain exactly yeah but that
being said yeah I don't know I I take it
back I don't know oh [ __ ]
excuse me I dealing there are some
things I miss about Lyman warfare like I
do like helicopters I think that's a
really neat way of like not just
providing your support but like
transport like you can get creative mmm
Nikki I'm pretty sure you can change the
graphical settings we can try in a
second pretty sure we did that last time
do what was the question
can you change graphical settings um yes
- no I don't think I I think they've
dialed back to the abilities of actions
yeah like it's all good
but maybe I mean like I said like we'd
have to check video yeah you can you can
definitely change settings some like
some stuff I mean but yeah yeah but some
oysters yeah but sure but somebody was
saying you couldn't do it so oh he says
you can't even change the grapples right
but see like we're definitely we had
change certain side yeah but we're
definitely there's stuff you can change
but anyways
Shannon asks I've got one simple
question is this the best battlefield
game you've played today does it feel
like it has improved I hope I hope that
we like I don't know like I feel like
this is the last time there was a close
alpha this feels pretty good but like I
cannot say or confirm something like
that right now right like yeah this is
this is so early because I've only seen
like what two maps on oh I think you're
dead oh look how close like it was
though I saved a little later yeah yeah
that being said like it's just like you
know how can i I can't I can't say that
like I can't say that with one map one
game mode or two I guess with no
progression like we can't go there yet
however that being said like this this
feels pretty good like I'm having a
pretty good time playing this game it's
a very small slice I feel like right
so you have to you have to dial back
opinions like that and I mean like
outside of I don't know building and
things like that you know oh yeah that's
the other thing too speaking a building
that you can build fortify that wall
once here maybe don't forget guys and
gals closed alpha is there any level of
destruction I mean it's more like kind
of right yeah there is
oh yeah because because because you can
rebuild certain spots right so like that
kind of fortification that Rob built
that can be destroyed I'm pretty sure
those sandbags that that guy was like
head camping or head glitching you on
just now something they built
potentially god I'm finally last bullet
yeah sandbags so those were things you
can destroy and then like buildings over
here there are some there are some
things you can and cannot like oh come
on oh you're right is a box or am I the
only one who thinks fortifications are
pointless I don't actually I think that
if you fortify properly it actually is
pretty hard to like get into the point
no not like not even general but like
I'm Bravo if you fully build it out and
you get the turret thing there too it's
super hard to get into it so like if
your squad knows what they're doing and
they actually fully fortify it it makes
it way harder to get into the point if
you're trying to take it back and also
it's like like less sight lines you
actually have to like almost like well
you definitely have to throw grenades
and things like that just to break it or
to like kind of like scare them off
camping behind them cuz I don't know I
found it like once they were set up I
was like oh what do I do now I guess I
either got to go around or like
someone's gotta like throw like smokes
or something no for sure and and the
other area where I would say that like
it's been pretty great he's like in
comparison battlefield one we're like
there were some air
is in that map were like wow there is
right there were some capture points in
battlefield one that like you could
level the entire area so you had no
obstacles or yet no cover whatsoever as
you were trying to capture it so with
this implementation like you can 100%
let's try a little playing here ok you
can now we're done what's up dude bro
you can allow sure like you can set up
some some cover in order to capture like
it's it's definitely like a helpful
addition catastrophic said Rob Sun is
here you have a son oh yeah is this lot
a sloppy noodle in the chat oh I don't
know slap you know oh boy
I see it's an inside joke but he is my
son could you see your son all right
not a bad not a bad first round we are
not gonna look at the scoreboard that's
for sure why not take a look at it okay
yeah peace for a first game the first
thing I asked me when I first saw you
was hey are you warmed up you're like
nope and you had like cream cheese I was
like yeah I guess he just got here so
that was like we're warming up you know
we're warming up with you guys in the
chat this morning thank you guys all for
tuning in
appreciate it if you haven't subscribed
think about that as we go live Monday to
Friday normally at 11 a.m. and it'll
notify you as to when we go live also
when put up cool like features reviews
previews all that kind of fun stuff
is it worth pre-ordering it's hard to
say if you're like on what is it Xbox
Xbox has the like early you get to play
like 10 hours right for like for like 5
bucks yeah as part of the leg I want to
say I would say if you have an Xbox I
would do that play for 10 hours see if
you like it and then decide if you want
to fully purchase it and then if not
probably try to get into the betas play
the betas and see if you like it but the
thing is I
with the beta's and all that I don't
know if you're gonna ever see the like
war stories or the single-player stuff
unless I'm mistaken which is very
possible I think the early game class
you can see yeah well I don't think the
beta is I still have single-player no
probably mostly multiplayer oh yeah you
guys are both after me he's got crash
he's done he's like I give up there's
two planes on me never pre-order it says
m1 Punk yeah I mean I don't generally
pre-order too much myself either but no
was that an ally no I don't pre-order
unless it's a game I know for sure like
I'm gonna play or want and like it
doesn't matter if i preorder or just
like buy it day of but in some cases
pre-ordering it does save you some money
sometimes like I don't know if deaths
gambit is still 16 dollars but it was
yesterday same with like dead cells when
I bought on PlayStation it was like 20
instead of 25 so like yeah like I know
I'll play this game with my buds so like
I'm here or console
that's a good question which is like I
wouldn't know I would want to play PC
but with my buddies I would I would play
ps4 just cuz my friends play I agree
yeah that's my problem too it's like I
want I still play destiny here and there
and I'm gonna play when the DLC comes
out and I really want to play PC cuz it
just feels a lot better and the field of
view is really nice but like I done of
my friends sans like maybe one or two of
them will switch so without the rest of
them I can trade so I will be on ps4 you
just have to play where you're I mean
that's what that's like the beauty and
the curse of like you know multiplayer
games and having the friends to play it
with you just sometimes you guys stick
with them on that platform yeah the
other bummer is I like flying planes
with a joystick mmm no joystick with ps4
what assault guns are on the game
there's a fun I think there's a couple
got you see stg44
no bread is kind of knotted AR Oh legs
are good you have you did not skip leg
day thanks good did not man I'm in the
thick of it Eric okay
chunks 420 are there naval battles I'm
sure there will be none on this or joins
the anchor join dance group tastes as
Bob Jones bomb dude I can't leave all of
them I'd be the greatest betrayal god
this coffee so strong I'm a weak boy now
there's no more planes I normally drink
my coffee black with this coffee I'm
gonna have to yeah guess we weren't able
leave him alone he got one of them right
yeah what was that was that like the
actual person could you imagine if you
got someone every time you do that
wasn't very natural that's not it like a
ghost that was terrifying man would talk
to you saying if battlefield 5 is
cross-play it'll be better with a more
with a bigger player base yeah um you
won't see cross play with Playstation
wish you know maybe you'll get lucky and
you'll get cross play with uh I doubt it
though it's really hard to like I don't
know I guess sport and I kind of does it
but like add your own you know what
you're getting yourself into but like it
it's really hard to have that debate
about having console versus of PC
players especially in the FPS games
because I feel like like let's take Call
of Duty for example right I was watching
some streamers play Call of Duty that
you know pop GE or for tonight I was
watching Shroud former pro csgo player
dude dude was just slaying like out of
his mind with like a pistol on PC
because he could just flick headshots
you would never see that on console so
like if we had cross play those people
would just like wreck yeah it's not like
the console people because technically
mouse keyboards more precise aim right
for sure so it's just hard for me to
believe that there would be cross play
for FPS games I mean I'm sure there will
be but I feel like PCs got such a has
advantages for sure they're gonna have
field of view they're gonna have you
know mouse keyboard and all that stuff
and if they're gonna do that I would I
would expect them to like filter you
know like hopefully you'd be able to
like not like if I was on ps4 I would
110 percent not want to play against any
PC people and you should I'm saying like
a filter as far as like like server
browser or some like that I don't know
that's possible I don't know if any
games actually do that the browser like
some games do with cross play you'd be
like I don't want to play chat sorry
yeah when we died I saw it too oh let me
double check I could turn vsync on when
you take down a tank without using a
vehicle I mean yeah you have very tight
tank type weapons is this bad or out no
it's not
the open beta did you say September
roughly I don't think there's a hard a
hard date but that's why I like a good
guess because it'd be a month before
right right Stuka console players have
nothing on PC yeah I mean I'm sure there
are some console players that could
probably hang with peace like good PC
players but in general I would just I
would my assumption is that PC is just
because of the advantages and
like they're gonna definitely probably
win that that battle between console pc
personally just in terms of like in the
FPS game that's the same f and mode so
far
yes Johnny we're all royal but hard to
say if things might not change perhaps
here did you guys are too slow planes
really duking it out here in the air oh
he's got a gun switch T sweats is just
one guy he switched to it he's like I
can't fly to get him gunner you have a
gun all right yeah I got two why are
they not doing their job they're trying
it's the thing about there they're
looking missing it's closed alpha
everyone know oh he got out he bailed
said I'm not winning this piece that's
true
michael says to drop bombs one to two
seconds earlier yeah I guess that makes
sense
am I upset at Playstation or Sony for
the lack of cross play um I mean a
little bit but in the I mean you'd be
selfish like I guess in this sort of
selfish like business mindset you can I
mean you have to think about it from the
other side of the coin like they don't
need to do it is how I look at it it's
like they have you know a good line
chair of the markets right which is this
is bad for just like in terms of like
for every gamer out there that just
wants to play with their buddies I know
it's bad like it's unfortunate it sucks
I don't disagree with that but like from
Sony's perspective they gain nothing
outside of like goodwill from people for
doing cross play I think they'll
actually potentially lose business by do
across way potentially but who knows I
could totally be wrong I just think that
there's business ramifications and
that's probably why so happy but take
that with a grain of salt
I mean I'd love to be able to you know
play destiny with people on PC and
console I guess but again like even with
that like I feel like I'm still not sure
if they would ever do that
just because like think about overwatch
right think about a blizzard game
they're not gonna commingle the two
because they're two like different
demographics right again PC just has
some advantages to it that console
players won't have even though you could
technically do a keyboard mouse into a
console but I heard like the latency on
that side super great
kinda guys like I'm done with this oh no
more Bob hello Mady do you never skip
like day hi friend
oh he's like nope nope Etsy dude you
guys are getting rekt I'm so gonna die
stenick says you're right Microsoft has
a console and PC market I mean like they
do as a like whole because that's where
their games live on but I'm pretty sure
there's still more players on ps4 than
Xbox seems a little quiet doesn't matter
what do you hear yeah well they have so
many other points that like what's
losing the town you know uh what's up
crime you asked a question I do not see
it oh there you guys hi Eric I'm late
with well the second beta be on consoles
any details no closed alpha the second
closed office still only on PC I believe
right see you know I'm sorry this closed
alpha the second closed alpha is only PC
yeah I'm pretty sure I'm pretty sure
yeah I'm like 90% sure Evan I answered
your question about assault guns
I believe there's the Bren there's the
stg44 I guess you could sort of say mp40
but that's like SMG
just depends on your using the mp40 now
right yeah so when you eject from a
plane as well you don't hear the gunner
class you're the pilot class so you
don't really have a whole lot as you can
see I have a flare gun let's give it a
whirl
shoot that at a person that's sick I'm
gonna stay here what do you think which
I move oh thanks Alfred or says most
players will forget about this game
after they had it for a month and move
on to the next best thing like they do
with every game I think that the
hardcore demographic of battle people
players don't do that they they continue
to play it I mean look at that they
support a battlefield 4 for a while
right
but that I feel like that a general
statement made against most gamers is
that a bad guy everything in front of
you yep
hello Nazis Robert
hello easy gaming Corbin stg44
aesthetics as I've played cut for beta I
think that's one you want to write and
this game looks better do you agree um
very different like like nap styled
games but I mean like yeah the the
battlefield traditionally like there
maps and stuff probably looked better
like I don't dispute that at all come on
I'm memory you got to think about it
like both games have been successful for
a long time because they are different
from each other I don't know I'm just
gonna let you guys argue about the OPF
gosh okay you're like a hamster yeah I'm
doing good hi hosts in the back man I'm
real flying this is really sick right
lay down oh yeah never know right oh is
that a tank where so you're right the
thing he just shot or was that person oh
it was a person dude this is next-level
right here trying to take Bravo or Baker
talk about an exploit they're gonna have
to patch this did they pick spotting I
[Laughter]
saw scope and did they give squad
leaders abilities I mean the squad
leaders had the ability to call him like
though v1 rocket right right yeah they
did
the other ability you have is to just
like as you did in bow for the one you
just tell your squad where to go okay
let's take me a Z Z a.m. no.1 says can
you attach mods to weapons you will be
able to they have not showed any of that
off yet o window where says y'all know
when the beta is gonna come out no our
guess is September sometime probably
like a month before what's up gaming
Mike asked hi guys what is your favorite
weapon real coal from World War two that
you think they should add and I'll defer
to Rob for this question I want to see
[Music]
would you say that the jawar is like the
m1 garand because I would add the m1
garand
they'll they'll add the m1 grand for
sure but I have to bring this back to
call of duty but that gun was like the
ping like the classic Oh Shh how doesn't
say if you saw that guy because I saw
someone laying down earlier oh it worked
out
there's no Alpha on console that's
correct yes but planes I don't know man
I want our vehicles wise I'm gonna see
what I want to see I want to see the
p-47 Thunderbolt it's a cool plane I
want to see Manny be cool he could fly
like four-engine bombers like a b-17
that'd be pretty awesome I'm gonna wiki
some vehicles to look up and then pick
one because that's where I'm at a lot of
Tanks Panzers up engines Sherman's for
Americans be cool you do like like
Normandy style landing craft remember
like you like Private Ryan like the like
the flick they're called them they're
called they were like swatting seven is
very kind of you is there bullet drop
yeah we've-- so will you read this gun
had some yeah there's some sort of
tweaks it's like oh did you get sniped
dude did he car 98 you yeah a car
tonight I'll change it up I suck
decrease the fall-off range from 50 to
50 I just like fall off range and a lot
of weapons weeks seems like they they
kind of like tweaked or nerfed a bunch
of guns
much like the STG max damage went from
27 to 21 if they're trying to like
increase time to kill yeah cuz that was
kind of a big thing right like like what
the mg34 got buff oh we know it's damage
range
yeah the SUV max damage okay I gotta
look her max damage instead of max
damage range
oh they increase the car 98 max damage
from 80 to 90
can't wait for those quick scope and
guys quick scope oh that was a headshot
come over here let's do this feel this
in G gun attachments will come later as
Rob said this one goes up soldier I'm a
medic - what are you doing Rob I had one
boy in my I guess technically the other
big thing like but they announced this a
while ago it was like there's no more
that weirdness with the what was it the
like everyone's on the same everyone's
playing the same game and not held back
by a man help me Rob do it it's it's
pretty it's this is early for us and
like the microtransactions and stuff our
outlet right oh sure oh yeah that's what
they said well battle packs or crates
yeah the crates are gone and then
there's like
dude are you kidding me yes
for the first time you you pay for what
you get literally free DLC no seasonpass
free weapon updates yeah so like
everyone's on the same playing field I
just didn't remember exactly all the
things that like they did but yeah which
is cool which is like very countered to
like what happened with like battlefront
which is why it's kind of a big deal
because I had to learn that lesson the
hard way I don't know it's so weird
though like I'm like happy that they did
the right thing and they you know
ultimately took microtransaction glad I
came but that's how that game should
have shipped you know what I mean oh for
sure
battlefront I would I mean it was a
pretty decent game like flying and that
game was pretty awesome and I like in a
way would the damage was done right like
I don't know like I I I may be playing
it in a different timeline or a
different world like I might be playing
it still today I think maybe a lot of
people would be as well
Pantera of all we stopped streaming to
twitch just so we can start focusing on
a few platforms instead of so many it's
part of the reason so we're trying it
out like I've said multiple times I
don't think that I've fully closed the
door on that but you know for now just
no streaming on Twitch so it's more
might be more selective right no
apparently not okay we'll figure out and
have a chat about right during like
Wednesday
you have 69 health right now Rob well
for tonight looks great yeah definitely
definitely
look guys they're building stuff for
tonight expansion confirmed just
refortified a building that was you know
shot out still no idea for a beta
release date see that he's moonwalking
falling down well that's like a thing
too right like the sliding and like all
the like scoochie little hidey-hole that
guy used to hit hide in to get be Oh
again I don't know when the beta is
coming to console y'all sorry I think
that we're guessing is September snipe
but who knows my good sniper well they
did buff the car as I saw they buffed
the damage on the car but they decreased
a Maxima range from twenty to eight
meters they decrease the damage fall-off
range from 80 to 60 decreased minimum
damage from 60 to 55 and they lure
lowered bullets exit velocity from 700
600
Oh was that the v1 v1
inhaling nothing though remember that v1
he shot last time that was worth it yeah
it was like a squad wipe yeah
World War 3 greater than BFI we haven't
even seen enough of World War 3
like I'm intrigued by that game but I'm
also like cautiously like worried oh
that that's right on a point with the
patch notes your minimum damage is 55
okay this is how I snipe in I want to
like feel like I'm I have no idea of
like where to lead or where not to you
know stay still you got a good Navy
you're not a medic right
oh yeah feathers right through there oh
right through there maybe I just had to
make these like bet challenges with you
where like you uh have like a lot of
money on the line like with that we took
out that airplane in the air oh right
right what a perfect time to jump we
could have nicked them in the leg
something bit Bay
Gamescom will be seen heard some rumors
I'll be showing off gameplay finally
it's possible it's in like what another
week or two next week next week yeah
next week
boring says Thiago I agree just getting
started
where I should try the out the Buffs
stuff to see what he thinks
um he was trying out buffs weapon
they're technically sort of if anything
that mg34 got the all everything was a
buff to the mg34 same with a Bren
so alright let's try that out can Eric
play just a little bit wide so you can
haze me no twos do you want to play no
I'm good
oh no ma'am
battlefield has just never been for me
yeah your aim is to do my aim is do do I
don't know equally to blame I blame the
game oh wow see yourself right out of
this room right now this game is so
broken
alright this is it now I'm gonna do well
in a tank
no alright I got a gunner
let's rock n roll
uh I don't know if Battle Royale is
confirmed as much as they called it
Royale I guess it'll be some form of
that but you don't know exactly what
that means
wait what were you talking
it's always just saying that battle
royale is confirmed and I said that it's
sort of but you know I mean it's
confirmed yeah like you said though it
wouldn't be like you know it's not gonna
be on release probably no it's not
they just were saying that they're doing
it well America for life says it's
better than black ops for like I said
these it's you can't the cod verse
battlefield thing I know it's ripe for
the arguing but they're kind of
different and especially this year
because it's not even they're not both
in a world war but how is that dead
you're gonna tase it didn't you should
be dead a medic
well issue to anti-tank yeah oh I he
might know what he's on he's on a gun
thing that's not good
get out one help how's the level of
destruction well you saw tankage to get
blown up
can you still completely level buildings
no but you can like damage them and then
the big like one of the big changes is
that you can kind of refortified some of
that back but it's confirmed yeah I
guess I want to see what it looks like
first I guess there's some type of
battle royale mode whatever that is
they're using the bread yeah so you
should be able to change your subclass
here for the mg 4042 let's give that a
shot
don't compare cod to battlefield they
have nothing in common well they
definitely have nothing in common this
year cod has become like more of like a
hero shooter like Rainbow six siege II a
little bit not totally
no I didn't kill you didn't do any of
that sick jump shooting the cons are you
see along the gun took the fire my god
takes time to spin up you know but if
you were if you maybe you should just
start pre firing and then jumping maybe
you should hey B I should just be always
firing always firing always be fired
always go here
I miss brother-in-arms as crystal says
black ops beta was a good change of the
cod series but you can't compare them i
play cod when i only have less than an
hour to spare when gaming and
battlefield when I have a full day make
sense like what are you getting hit by
it's guys the left dude I am about to
throw this computer yeah let's watch it
let's watch it I'd like to see it yeah
all right I can't I just have to fall
back into this medic class I can't dude
I can't okay whatever you need to do
please tell me what skill you need in
Call of Duty uh if you're playing
against good people you have to have
some twitch reactions because I don't
know man some of the someone's like some
of the folks with the jumping SMG
tactics are pretty good and yeah if you
can't react to that you're gonna have a
bad day that's all I gotta say look
we're just not gonna have any like weird
bad or any type of negativity or any
type of stupid comments about how this
isn't historically accurate and blah
blah blah that's just silly
it's really old and you know what for
one so we're just gonna police it in
chat
you know that's just how it is I'll
donate $50 if you flip the table and the
PC somehow that doesn't seem like it's
worth it because of how much we would
lose
not only the PC I don't care about the
table but the PC is so quick reactions
is the only skill I mean you got to be
able to aim
if you can't aim then that doesn't mean
anything either it's a twitchy shooter
was he using OMP 40 so you got to be
behind a little barricade Rob got a head
glitch um it's blitzie dropping good
knowledge here don't get angry because
you're gonna lose your focus and your
vibe oh damn
it's true you once you go on tilt
there's no going back off of the tilt I
mean this is how we felt towards the end
of the last no I think Aaron wants to
squat up oh he can squat up on me yeah
because he was like what time are you
shooting bf5 and I'm like we're
streaming he ready there's no water
vehicles in this al flower map
Wow car 98 did you of close that guy's
so good look like he was like what level
21 it looked like he was putting that
what's up snap KD looks like one map
yeah keep up the positivity guys I gotta
get back to work thanks Chad have a good
one thanks for stopping by thanks for
the questions and comments appreciate
how you get this - cyborg man I think
because we had the first alpha we it
just Auto invited us to the second alpha
what do you think about insurgency
sandstorm I've already played the beta I
can't wait to play it again on the 30th
as I talk I actually haven't played
sandstorm it looks interesting and
that's I'd have to defer to Aaron
because he actually got to check it out
more recently so yeah do you squad why
not depends I don't know if Aaron's in
the opposite
the real question is is Red Dead - worth
it as I'm here
I don't know we just saw gameplay
trailer for it which is pretty cool one
of like potentially many there's one to
your left and possibly uh near the fence
like he was in the house okay oh oh
maybe he's your guy that died then get
up the last guy Oh Rusty's in the house
Oh slide prone almost he Carden I needed
YouTube anyone map doesn't really look
like there's enough space for any kind
of tactical play though the maps pretty
big
we're only been to a couple points and
as I mentioned you definitely need to
try to rebuild or refortified something
spots and you'll get oh geez give them
the quick stabby stab with the triangle
around them I was gonna tell you just to
provide both of them call it a day the
stairs though when this console get to
play my guess is September Davos but
yeah there's no confirm date or anything
Oh America for life I don't know like I
feel like yeah it's more skill-based in
the sense that like time to kill is
longer and like there's health pack and
stuff like that but it's still like it's
still run and shoot as much as because I
was alright there's a lot of people that
were definitely run and gunning with
smg's despite even the S&P is getting
nervous so I think that Cod is still
more that style except it's a little a
little slower pace than usual do you
like the new bleed out mechanic um I
thought it was fine I guess it makes
sense because then it it does leverage
the classes as we had talked about the
last dream I think
you know your medic has had their
important episode like and that promotes
squad based stuff like you want to spawn
your squad you want to stick with them
stealth McCree saying cause no longer a
random spray and shoot require school
yeah it does only in the sense that like
it takes longer to kill someone so yeah
but I still think that you can run and
gun cuz a lot of people were still doing
that so like if you're really skilled at
running gunning then like it's gonna
work out but there are some characters
in the in the cloud Raider that can slow
down gameplay a little bit like torque
instead of that we're talking about
battlefield 4 now yeah also has bullet
trajectories still thing yes spirits um
as mentioned by dark Vipers sniper it
isn't alcohol so yeah no is that closed
off look so this is nowhere necessarily
indicative of what its gonna look like
even come beta but who knows so far
outside of progression and some of the
weapon changes and squad better squad
stuff
okay Jesus didn't see him come closer
that's the car 98 guy
Carnegie bullet yeah why can't they have
an open beta it's a good question Kevin
I'm not sure they will they will
eventually they're currently test
Bukhari says they're testing level up
leveling up system or progression system
and server stability servers are being
pretty stable in my opinion what I think
it sees behind you again is that sniper
alright just camping to get a objective
based gaming that's grenade salt Bay
runs better after alpha one I think it's
about the same progression system is
obviously different and there's some
weapon tweaks we haven't really tried
the squad stuff that they improved on I
mean well they kind of straight-up just
implemented it cuz it was very broken I
said I don't know like I don't know if
there's what else oh I mean I'm actually
squad leaders I could probably I don't
even realize that I wasn't so someone
labs like there it was just broken it's
all like other than giving commands I
don't think there's anything else they
can do well you can actually your squad
leader you eventually get to call in the
one rock and stuff like that there was a
guy down yeah yeah
what
yeah yeah that's cool you're using that
iron sight huh
I'm not trying to I don't know this is
an accident no this is broken you're so
good that you're gonna use your iron
sight dude I'm not trying to do this
this is this is a bug this is the think
you are but okay so it's a good war but
it thinks you have the car is that
what's going on no it's just not because
he doesn't know dude it's a bug it's
it's thinking I don't have a normally
have that scope on the guar I thought
that was on the car 9e8 no this is the
Guevara with a scope I don't know I was
gonna wear with the scope I didn't know
that it always had it goes I don't know
I thought it looked like the car to me
no so I don't know if you're confused
like the the images of guns don't show
the they just show the base gun they
don't show like scopes on them so that's
what's kind of confuse I'm ready for Bad
Company 3 heck yeah yeah company 3 and
then someone saying pack up through
three had like never coming coming out
never
swapping Scott squads works I tested it
yeah that was the thing you couldn't do
is you couldn't create or swap squads so
they like nice so that's cool I sense
the sarcasm there gamer but good to have
you oh god sorry I'm probably butchering
that gun I'm just gonna call it the gun
the G guns give it I think it's
pronounced give you bear give way give
there you just pronounce the W with as a
V this is like this is like pretty to
Bridget Bridget Bridget that's not a bug
as a feature no way I don't know that's
what gams that says God and I don't
think that guy was trolling but
why would you ever want to swap because
I know what your site would be like for
shorter-range right and like what was
that useful in any fashion though I mean
I guess I get to see I think you were
just more confused by it I mean maybe I
can see like more around me right like
stuck it it's all good
totally nothing bad happened there at
all the medic right no no no sick dude
oh hi hello there dude I am playing like
great such garbage you're playing great
no I'm not better than me no you might
be need to play and I don't know into a
room and cry under a table battlefield
guy though I don't care okay all right
you got it I'll do whatever you say
that's what you want we can make it so
do we want to try that other long-ass
mode yeah is even worth it I don't know
it's up to you there's multiple days and
that one I want to throw this no no no
you're definitely not doing any of that
and tell you to leave this room before
doing that I don't think they did
anything too much performance wise the
Luke stir it's just more for the
progression system and then the squad
stuff that they've kind of improved upon
he dropped a smoke if I'm not gonna help
you woo he's back there's another one
there's another one although you
wouldn't I saw that guy but there was
definitely one in front of you grand
operations is fun guys you try it you
can give it a go alright let's try it
Ravi's a teammate who would have who
would help rez I would have killed that
guy possibly never no crime oh you're
good
oh yeah
Oh No grenade come from that ruined your
line of sight and I just wish push ahead
like yeah we'll see you games that
really hard to say well shook up a small
swing no this game had like the biggest
thing that's missing this game is wall
running okay so titanfall got it good
morning
Harry man hey look it's your plus and
this is it only first-person yeah oh
yeah yeah that's battlefield well if you
count vehicles their squad whatever
those twins the car goes I do want to
see some customization down the road
with this game alright sure you're gonna
do some grand just go to school try
you're gonna operate Bramley let's go no
definitely not
maybe ooh no signal did you kick
something no no no you know what somehow
like as you're doing that it changed you
got change this this video settings you
know cuz it basically like alpha changed
resolution on itself should be good now
what I don't know buddy
we're trying to fix the resolution it's
like now it's black flickering to its
own thing
Oh
know by now nope
I can hear it yeah
do I try restart this monitor hang in
there everyone it like what to sleep
well you can try flickering it but I
don't think that's gonna do anything
because it's basically like not seeing
the signal which is fun
don't worry objective Baker will
eventually get there scanning for the
HDMI hold on this is fun all tab out
should we throw the computer
says it's going back to sleep again hang
in there everyone what did I kick
something
there's no way
oh hi son hi son yep that worked nice
all right we're back back into it that
was the game telling us we waited with
Squatch I try that dude that sounds
awful I don't you do you do whatever you
want it's alpha oh they gotta say yes or
no though
joke's on you I hope would be messed up
they're quitting Oh is Erin with me I
don't know I don't know why anyone else
would come with me looks down computers
on fire nope still good not on fire it's
a little I'm gonna say it's because Rob
was excited I really need to push those
cables back it happens too often it's
your fault then well the thing is every
time I set it up one way things get like
pushed around and I can't keep it the
way it is so that's what I'm gonna say
just push everything back later I'll
just I'll just cut my legs off no you
just need to get good F and that's gonna
be the stream for today everyone thank
you so much have a great rest of the
week yeah you wish you wish your your
little delayed little delish does the
stream know but you're like shackled to
this table true nothing taking a fix
thanks Chris Papp you got it figured it
out when in doubt it's always a loose
cable recede your cables it's really
like Comcast customer service when they
really you always got to ask did you
restart did you have you check the power
have you checked your actual connection
have you receded your connection and all
those failed then you should just google
it why don't I have signal and then
it'll probably prompt you to read the
same things I just said probably mmm-hmm
not a whole lot of people playing the
old grand operation
what always did take us a while to get
into those games but yeah most people
are probably playing conquest can you
customize your MP 40s gender in this
case I read that well I don't know I got
that sounded pretty genuine at first but
you can yeah you can totally customize
the skins down the road everything's
gonna be cosmetic right everything to be
cosmetic count thanks Devon appreciate
it assuming I said your name right we're
gonna wait till the estimated time and
if it doesn't make it then I'm just
gonna sell him to play conquest or I can
play and then die alot and then you can
you can be the one to heckle me yeah I
don't know man you seen you seen me play
I'm not too bad I can be okay
say something I could be okay I playing
this yeah thanks
I don't feel so good I'm gonna go home
sick this is a pepto-bismol
our specs okay yeah they're good
what do we have Eric 1070 it says right
there that post-it note now and forever
when anyone asks about PC this PC no
that doesn't work it's it's an i7 780
700 K with the 1070 and 32 gigs of ram
those are the most important things and
that is always going to be on this
monitor now because apparently people
get asked all the time in here
especially when I'm not in here and
please play Eric says crime crime just
wants to watch me die so that he can
heckle me master Ricky failed sick all
right back to context all right
you know what Ivan I've been a loser I'm
gonna play really well now all right I
don't know with that kind of attitude I
don't know if you are but I'll take you
I've been good I I'm gonna I'm gonna
play like a badass now okay you just
needed your coffee to kick in mm-hmm
only a 1070 yeah I mean we have 10 80s
outside that's the funny part only at
1070 what are you rocking maybe at 10:10
WTI is not that much better it is a
little bit but I mean I don't know we're
only doing 1080 gaming in here so it's
like how much more do I need than a 1070
right don't say anything bad Eric we're
trying to play it close we're trying
it's you're looking for a game now was
it a mistake to try to do grant
operations possibly can't you see the
screen we're finding a game I'm not
gonna go run down to EA headquarters and
you know do it myself
all right fallout 76 hype yeah it should
be good I mean that beta is what
September 2 I think yeah we should
probably find out I'm pretty sure
September other guy operation server is
disabled I don't think so I mean you're
you can click on it right now but it was
even in the first alpha it was kind of
hard to get into a game yeah it was
especially grant operations so that's
not really much of a surprise even if I
do that crime nobody would look for it
and we'll still ask the question so Bob
Bob Jones is right I think the game
broke with that bug I mean I probably
haven't said it was a matter dude
there was also a bug that was like we're
making people play really bad Oh was it
yeah let's see towards the bottle yeah
it says like so much some we're
live-streaming some players will
experience stage fright here we go 3 to
10 70 is for scrubs get your wait up I
guess I guess a 10 MP 1080 weighs more
than a 1070 so we're going by weight of
graphics cards and I should hit the gym
oh man I never hit the gym that's my
downfall yeah my downfall in life ain't
that - yes Lewis there will not be any
ma it's not that there isn't
microtransactions it's just there's no
microtransactions like that affect the
game right
everything's cosmetic so it's more like
that overwatch route I think oh Lord
that's great place to spawn what that's
a real cool spawn I like that right now
did they fix planes yet nope ok Ellen
says I can't wait to play this game yeah
hopefully beta will be around you know
September's that y'all can I know so
y'all can get in and play with us it's
ok you drop those health packs because
you knew he was gonna need them that's
right
do you play for tonight we do sometimes
not as much as we used to because now we
yeah some of me here he comes
he's alive oh that planes after him
though yeah get in a foxhole this looks
like a good place to hide that'll
protect you suicide that should have
worked I blame the game mm-hmm I didn't
want to say anything because I was like
here he comes and that's like nope no I
thought you were gonna do one of those
quick switches back to your you know
your rifle I should of that would
freaked him out Oh God
a plane oh dude good work are you high
for spider-man yeah I'm yeah it looks
good I hear the movement and the cook
like I mean they saw me act knows how to
do movement oh sunset overdrive which is
one of those underrated games I feel
like yeah I really definitely had good
movement so like it was just this guy
the game was cool stop chatting everyone
for a second I need to get rid of
someone hopefully I did to the right
person
nope I didn't I'm so sorry Oh what did
you do I booted someone that I shouldn't
have but this is like such a silly
system you should just be able to click
their name
I'm so sorry gamer battlefield if I
could untie me loud I would but you
booted a fan maybe I can't on time
amount I don't even know I am so sorry I
had to get rid of the other guy dude the
other guy was like way worse I forget
you I know you do but that other guy
might not I bet he does and she just let
Ryan do it but he's not totally staring
at it I don't think I don't know why
this guy is still trying to get us to
Ulta for it's such a like old bad joke
oh is that like a unsaid codes for all
weapons alt f4 plus a bunch of numbers
it's like yeah I'd really good try would
a code for all weapons well this is 97
exactly black sheep Walt that's pretty
hard yeah
at least you hit him you got hit markers
is it while beating fortnight on Twitch
it's possible BFA came out yesterday
battle for Azeroth usually wouldn't
excuse me an expansion comes out a lot
of the there's a lot of variety
streamers that end up playing that for
like you know the first month or two
like maybe pre-raid or maybe they'll
rate like a little bit and then oh
they'll call it quits but a lot of those
guys go and play well so that's not
shocking but it is so crazy that while
is number one I guess but every time
there's a in expansion usually over
horse your tank hilarious is just like
knocks you back once you back that was
shall not pass I was watching last night
that's a random question but okay hey
guys what's your favorite amusement park
ride whenever what Park I kind of fell
off amusement parks okay like five years
ago but that drop zone you drop the Top
Gun drop some Top Gun now not Top Gun
anymore because they don't own the
rights to it mount space balance of
classic didn't they turn talk on into
something else
no it's the same ride it's just called
something else that's I'm saying yeah
they just can't use the they don't have
the license to use Top Gun which is
unfortunate because I always like
waiting in line and listening to date in
his own crisis era can I help with motto
stop my silly jokes that's not for me to
decide I leave that in the capable hands
of anvil one gaming who basically runs
our YouTube channel
yeah I would jump out of that building
we still there come on oh crap
that's all right so this only tickle my
shooting Tex
haha we found a rear okay do we survive
Hey Oh how come that repair didn't go
off because he got hit yeah if you get
hit it's pretty good good dark sorry
dude oh this guy please play battlefield
4 live he's gay
oh they're both getting really cheeky on
you there's one guy right in front of
you and there's a guy to your right
why didn't you just run him over
I'm slow as f he was right he's
literally playing chicken with you but
as a human I know okay it wouldn't work
okay also hindsight you know ya don't
need 20 yeah maybe I'll see myself out
oh I'm a squad leader tune in tomorrow
as well as Thursday and Friday tomorrow
I think we're gonna play desk gambit
curious I think Joey and Jake are
playing that game and you know we might
be having a little boom of like 2d
side-scrolling platformer in action
games especially with like dead cells
haven't come out last week and then
Thursday I think we're slated to have I
think Sam's gonna play the Xbox games
with gold the free games with gold so I
think Forza horizon 2 is still free for
the whole month and then I'm blanking on
the other game think it's out on the
15th or 16th I'll look that up and then
Friday we're gonna have community oh
wait before that there's great hoppers
on Thursday is it you and Marian yep 2
p.m. we're Rob and normally Mike put
permadeath in every game Mary rips in
about 5 minutes
in Resident Evil 4 I kind of had this
feeling she was thrown into the fire I
felt bad for Mike because Resident Evil
was the first game guys ever made it
through but you're doing fine right now
right in master mode yeah I should be
okay
oh my god
so yeah come back Thursday for that 2
p.m. for grape hoppers then Friday will
be our community stream day where John
Luke and Ben are gonna play some games
with y'all so come get that out great
hoppers will be fun too
yeah yeah okay you're gonna see you're
gonna play after this okay you got it
oh this free game I mean we're down to
keep going yeah yeah yeah yeah go for it
to like another 30 minutes or more maybe
high CPU usage how that's not good
there's nothing else I could turn off
all right I'll kill Chrome I guess
that's so interesting what do you mean
oh I have another contact
will this work with a gtx 750ti I mean
actually I think we just put up an
article recently about the PC spec
requirements I should look that up for
you assuming this isn't break PC specs
well this was just for announced for
closed alpha so let's see alright I'll
just go with the June 28th one says for
processor AMD FX 8350 for the minimum I
cor i-5 6600 K 8 gigs of ram graphics
cards nvidia geforce gtx 750 or gtx 660
2 gig or four AMD radeon HD 7850 2 gig
that's minimum specs 50 gigs of hard
drive space the recommended however is a
processor AMD risen 3 1300 X or Intel
Core i7 4790 or equivalent with 16 gigs
of ram or 12 gigs of ram graphics card
recommended is a gtx 1060 and/or AMD
Radeon our X 480 so there you go
that was as of June 28th though so
the harddrive space for this I think
when it launches is I think if that
article is correct was 50 gigs at least
you trade it there one for one baby
that's how I look at it I'm always
looking to trade so if I get a kill and
then die I'm like alright I did
something while 1050 minimum yeah but a
1050 is kind of yeah it's not that bad
later dark Vipers never enjoy your
dinner dinner yeah must be on the double
time it's crazy I think people are
getting dinner barely have breakfast
yeah those were recommend expects as of
June end of June though so you know I
don't know if those will hold true on
release but that that at least gives you
a baseline go for it yeah
your legs are conditioned for it
I think I'll be fine though Hattie and
you try the support you can okay so I'm
done I'll try the support plate like a
dog like dog do today
doc good do sick cool
all right we're trading spots I'm not
really gonna do better but how do i what
do I do in this game hi grandma
yeah I played like crap yeah no you did
all right three yeah twenty-eight
grandma 36 okay talk to you later
cool you're gonna play so much better no
I told you man I'm not a bad for the guy
I'll try playing support for whoever
asked I'm gonna die a lot see I play
this game like it's Call of Duty I run
and gun and you really shouldn't do that
miss Kay no you shouldn't well that's
what I kept fighting myself on was like
alright do I do I engage or do I like
make an effort to like a new game Robin
so which ones support medic it's alright
support no it's a machine gunner alright
you got it
mg34 no problem deploy me deploy you
gotta do this you gotta do those this
jump shooting dude I don't have a good
vertical
where should we go should we go to Baker
where's my squad leader man where are we
supposed to go or am i squatters shoot
how do i cue the objective I lost five
health frickin dropping down there don't
worry we're gonna get Baker I'm all
about objective based gaming
dude this is do I have to tripod this
thing is that even a thing or bipod
it'll auto setup when you go prone or
like take the cover against something
we're going to D Delta go to DS oh wait
it did it for a second oh that's awkward
you see that you see it's kind of out
thank you crime as man zero one says do
you protect or do you attack well you
kind of do a little bit of both you go
to because actually you could just
protect what you just sit on me good I
mean this is all bridge as a hot zone
yes do it
I took it won't and will not okay they
go it will not bipod on this thing oh
there you go you just have to wait you
just gotta
you really gotta let it do its thing yes
all right feeling good Rob yeah feeling
good cuz I'm not that's a that's a long
fall and okay oh no there's a guy there
oh there's a guy there - all right
cyborg ninja says you remember - to
deploy the bipod I mean I guess you he's
just saying get the weights for it to
auto setup it takes it takes a second
for it to show see here you go these
guys are for fun I should just sit here
like alright alright there it is there
it is in time you're good to go
hope no one Snipes your face why do you
gotta put that in my head
roller coaster there oh yeah dude
oh dude GoPro and zzzzz oh hell yeah
dudes come on come down this way I know
you guys want Baker aisle dude I wish I
could provide these guys thank you
outgoing bot what are these guys what
yeah that's not gonna question it that's
realistic oh here we go
oh dude yes
yeah
now we're talking hot zone come at me
come on where's the last guy I'm here
come get me how far is that guy oh okay
that's a good snipe a lot of KFC versus
McDonald's who know one or the other
McDonald's has more options then KFC's
real good though I only like KFC
biscuits I guess yeah I'm a hot wings
kind of guy oh I get out of this thing
oh yeah let's get a out of five hi I'll
have to go McDonald's I get the same
thing every time I go McDonald's alright
what's your go-to medium fry and then -
do you know about Friday's sorry well -
double no two leaders are you guys going
to beta or be Baker Baker oh there's so
many people at Baker let me take that
back what are we talking about Friday's
fridays mcdonald's has a thing now where
you can buy pie
where you get the boys at the medium fry
large fry with like a 4-legged as long
as you purchase all hours I'm like that
yeah something like that
as long you like make a purchase or some
like that deal Whataburger I've had
burgers okay but I think you need to
have the I want the bipod how are you
alive cuz I'm a I'm a stud your stud
except for our friend 59 got me from the
back Uncle Dan fee says Taco Bell over
everything else that's fair I can't do a
Taco Bell Rex my stomach I don't I don't
think it does everything
no just probably no I yes sir I'm just
saying that that's surprising cuz I feel
like all fast food will wreck my stomach
no like oh like it's always gonna be a
bad time post consumption I shouldn't
want that
yeah whatever we have three spots
oh I don't agree with that what sigh boy
says uh Burger King is better
ooh the BK I don't know I like BK
because of the the chicken sandwiches
well act back when they had fancy areas
good chicken sandwiches that's fair they
used to have like fancy ones but I don't
think they did they do that anymore I
used to get the French chicken sandwich
it had ham and Swiss cheese and the
chicken oh man
delightful you know that's my friend
alright so I think we all agree Popeyes
is better than case how does I'm doing
this pipe odd thing wrong how I don't
know I'm just right clicking to like
well you can't set up a standing I know
but like on hair if I'm on the hill it
doesn't why can't I just have them like
okay no you know what it makes sense it
makes sense why I'm even questioning it
is crazy why I'm playing the way I'm
playing right now though he's also crazy
running good I'm part gonna regret this
Keifer barnes i would match Whataburger
with in and out that guy's an idiot that
was well played by me okay you're a
badass that's right he never he never
saw a coin
yeah oh just like I know he's cut he was
hiding he was hiding okay he was hiding
and he got me and this other guy yeah
well he watched me kill his friend
though yeah if you think about it that's
choice he knew you were coming yeah
exactly I can't shoot out of here that's
lame
oh we're at a though Adam [ __ ] oh shoot
that's a guy are we not capturing this
Oh buddy so slow it's so slight old you
I say no because we gotta buy potted
okay yeah gosh darn it
we need to get to alpha from where in
front of me got it
we need a perch no we don't oh you're in
the house damn it
cyborg man says 100 McNuggets live
stream again no thanks how many did you
eat what's the max I can only do like
maybe 80 now that's horrible
even the baby's horrible man for those
who don't know when was the last time
you did that was probably 2 years ago
yeah I didn't do it last year because I
just my body can't handle that yeah that
makes sense
we do a whole that's a tank we took an
anti tank I do not
can I just pump it full of wood hey you
we do a charity 5 & 6 now
and Eric as a stretch goal how do I
change glasses has eaten a tea chicken
nuggets McNuggets wait till you get to
deploy so left
oh no yeah you got all right we're gonna
go assault use an STD what about alpha
we need to get to Alice [ __ ]
Oh Oh all right come on Connor blow is
it on that's if it's on Xbox it's not on
Xbox yeah this is just Oh
nice I'm glad you're playing got him
they're gonna spawn here though it's a
problem
they're definitely at or were at a own
okay we're ready now to clarify nice was
a Connor that's that yeah Connor its it
will be obviously on Xbox launch and I
believe in open beta is around the
corner in September it's not good but
right now it's just on PC no oh I was a
good shot yeah I was a good shot I
shouldn't have done that
should I don't know where I could have
ran I guess I could have fell down into
this ravine or whatever of course over
the years it would probably be closer to
200 nuggets no thanks Joey
oh there's a tank going - oh do we have
the means to kill that tank though
whatever I'm going for Charlie your
assault right yeah oh hell yeah you do
umm yeah he's 400 I if I had known that
sooner
serpentine should love to punch it guys
the left really oh yeah oh yeah oh no
they see me where's my auto region
that's cute
good job by that guy he didn't just run
straight
I'm so used to Cod I shouldn't be able
to help pack myself I do like that
mechanic in Cod keeps the game at ieave
them Oh was that a No okay what Oh
planes aren't broken I just don't think
they're fine ESTs quite yet as far as
the box whole last bullet didn't see
that oh no he was over there I was down
here - I was let's say the window good
shot good shot good shot good shot good
shot
that's all right like I said just trying
to hope her at that one-to-one rah
she's got a hug right one two one got a
bait my teammates and get kills squad
one oh is that bad guy no it's a good
guy Civil War says is this on second
game gear no you wish wish there's this
guy behind you oh good okay okay we're
kind of covering each other there's a
guy in the house no you died no help me
the Chilean CFS why can't I squad spawn
on him he's in the GD tank sir Shizuka
says why's battlefield 5 World War two
it makes no sense I think it makes a lot
of sense
if they're in the previous game was
World War one it's been a long time
since we've had a world war two
battlefield game
hey guys are setup that's ridge that
guy's calling something in
we are going for C ok reload then good
job Spacey the Communists says heat gain
spot I'm French and I preordered for
valve field 5 do you have any
information on the private beta release
I don't think they're doing a private
beta
I believe they're they're going from
closed alpha to open bit no they do take
that back they do a private beta and
then they do an open beta I would expect
that to be around September both of
those how do we not have C yet is it
because they're contesting oh I saw
someone
how do we not have see it you have it no
we don't now you do okay
I think I was that guy maybe holding us
up
oh okay well I guess a fair I don't know
Daniel
clarifies pinkie men why battle why
battlefield one is World War one and
World War two is about bill five I I
would actually blame it was a weird
choice to go from battlefield 4 to 1 cuz
then your neck I don't know you're gonna
do battlefield 2 again then that's just
confusing because there already was a
battlefield 2 so I don't know I think
it's it's always funny when they create
different ways of like refreshing a
series out of the way go for a ye ditch
he's in that he's in that Depot isn't he
for that house oh well at least we got e
for Edgar dude we're so losing Edward
didn't see me you didn't see me oh I'm
right there wait so bathroom 1942 is one
my favorite games of all time I'm I'm
sorry
Platt oh [ __ ] scurs a plato's whiskers
sorry I might as I mentioned the desert
maps in 1942 they were awesome Ghazala
allowed me on god those games or those
maps are so great they're so big that's
why I love the bomb I love the how they
had like an airfield in the top-left for
I think was Gazala like it was a does
not is not go that far it was an
objective or if you took it then you got
the b-17 and then you could like carpet
bomb the opposing bases that's why I
missed about battlefield games is like
at least since what I mean three did
last I believe where you had like
runways and actual bases that you could
like take over and away or like push
them so he - I'm sodac - their face that
was so neat now you just auto take off
and playing this it's kind of uneventful
yeah the bots the bots what played oh
we're so good the box in 1942 had it you
could do like co-op BOTS is really fun
which apparently they're gonna have in
this game like co-op 4 player co-op I
think maybe more than that okay so we
don't have see I'm so confused right now
oh cool
maybe that's right September September
4th private beta confirmed really hope
there's a person in front of
don't worry I'll get Delta by myself
come on
squad SWAT on me we'll die together
there's a totally a dude up top dude
dang that's not it you got a couple I
was kind for the triple I was trying for
the hero mode triple there I was trying
to get my play of the game
stupid pissed so I should just ran up to
him and stab him oh this is a bad idea
look at this fortification that they got
going on here well again be though
we got be shy get D wait what what is
that someone rez dracco or no give him
health and Jack I was still looking man
yeah he believes whoa oh there's a whole
slew of them
yo there's like four of them there
they're all there assaulting thee
requests for ammo always sounds weird
oh no Drago is dead I have no squad
spawn now dude we lost B how do we lose
beer hold freakin teams at D oh here
this is that cheeky spot right to get be
back if it works chill here dude we got
it you and me Drac oh oh thanks thanks
for that yeah yeah yeah so you want to
capture be getting hide down here you
got forced to come down to you and we
got B we're gonna go for Delta they know
I'm coming from that side let's wrap
around the old wrap around the old
[ __ ] on me dude
I'm tragic be on the open that's bad I
[Music]
don't know what I was doing I was trying
to run away I think someone should
intervene you from the ridge should've
been down there to be honest
nice you're up there
doing all right fifth on your team doing
all right so are you excited for the
America oh yeah game looks good I'm yeah
I hope it's like it looks like they're
not doing they're doing enough right
yeah that's a good point they're doing
like I just don't want I liked what they
had so if they gave me more of that I'm
already in a good place
I mean now is the thing though is like
like I I hope they don't change it up
too much because I really like the last
doom like oh I would want is more of
that story I think that's one of the
biggest things that I think they show it
off like it like the mobility was really
great and I moved a little like whatever
the side whatever the little jet
boosting oh yeah the side dashing and
the grapple but the one moment that sold
me was when you walk into the UAC like
facility and all those guys
eat all those guys like are just
terrified of you walking through yeah
cuz you don't man me man Oh like I did
not know what happened he did not see
that coming
no I didn't either honest I do not have
a full round of ammunition here
what's so bad can a single player take
out a tank with explosives and rockets
yeah I takes a little bit of time make
some time but if you're skilled enough
absolutely
don't die next to him doing this for you
I'm gonna die doing it though was not
worth he appreciated that no I really
should have just went 4d weird that um
in that case it didn't ask me for revive
is it because I was our squad was dead
you know I mean it didn't do that like
you want oh my lord
yeah
nice
they're so gonna come up not even gonna
bother just give yourself away come on
come up here like I was an idiot and run
by me I'm shooting at that guy Brian a
bear wants to know what the improvements
from the last alpha not a whole lot
nothing drastic like content and then
it's pretty much the exact same map
grand operations mode same weapons the
main improvements were like I think just
overall performance and then they they
kind of tinkered with the they did a
bunch of balancing with weapons but they
also tinkered with like the progression
and how you rank up and and made sure
that the squad system was working there
are some bugs last time where you
couldn't switch squads or even create a
new one Stasi the Communist asks tell us
how EA made the v1 sound I don't know I
don't know how they did that it sounds
like a sounds like a crappy car engine
from downtown
it's not impossible there we're not even
like lands what just happened
oh that was a v1 I'm still good doesn't
sound like your teammate was I don't
expect them to be but they might be
looping around from a squeezed out
rebuild here it's T here let me rebuild
yeah now I feel good now I can't put one
here that doesn't make sense
yeah how you guys liking my camping
style holding down D
should we go after alpha probably or we
just rebuild our fortifications this is
a Minecraft you're such a team player I
like getting points Rob for free
what okay
Oh Spacey the Communists he knew he was
just asking for it
all right you showboatin what money day
he knows the the audio for the he was is
actually a truck engine from swiss it
has the same engine pretty weird
actually and that's cool
i always like hearing about stuff like
that my legs like Star Wars always has
like interesting facts I'm like how they
got that I was low real well on there
unlike what sound effects oh where were
you even you're down boy
3 again oh three by that guy he's had
the better of me what headphones are we
using no they're so nice and the MV ours
or whatever studio whatever just look up
so nice to do and you're so nice to do
headphones yeah oh dude worried we need
to take a or year something
I like to go after all right fine you
guys are all committed to uh-oh
that's another v1 rocket heads up oh
we're dead anyway he's gonna 43 ticket
hello
sounds real closer no it doesn't all
right got my squat he owe me how is he
okay
getting shot still oh use right in front
of me there Kevin Taylor I don't think
that's true the v1 rocket was not only
used days before the war ending the
battle britain if that was plenty
[Music]
I am it II
when are the non snowy gameplays coming
out we don't know yeah it's a good
question good question
we'll have to see all right all my
success but has been a delta all my
kills have basically come at Delta
therefore we're going to Delta
and we got one dude over there Oh am I
getting the v1 rocket mixed up with v2
rocket again are you know ya wasn't the
v2 rocket we have 12 tickets or lives
left
[Music]
no way that guy killed me right okay
with another guy I was like there's no
way
dude you just ran by someone you could
have revived cool maybe I should have
called for help that's that's what it
was
nope and that is that that's it push
idea I play one more should we call it
what do you think I wanna play one more
yeah you do yeah I don't know what I'm
doing though maybe I shouldn't I don't
think I'm gonna top my previous score
which is already not super great keep
going dude you're doing better than me
for sure you warmed up early in the
morning we're not ready yet yep
that's how I feel I'm sick of the modern
jet as well Kevin Taylor drop in the
history on us first v1 was launched at
London 44 so Vav within me the bear they
were both used so v2 rockets something
else before V ones right no I'm all like
second guessing this up as you should as
I should
what's this Oh dinah dinah my charges
huh
look at that lens that seung-ah or is
there snapper up on that hill up there
go to bake up oh yeah
try Mir on the mountain it's the God of
War Mountain
well how is my entire squad dead cuz you
have one kiss god Oh Billy Billy be
Slayer well having a draconian oh you
got another guy here tell him to go
places he's not on my squad no but tell
your squad where to go
yeah get slot points let's see if we can
get a a V to rock in the end don't mind
me guys just building for it dude
what no that's good look at her points
I'm getting racking it up as my squad
fills out here look at you all the way
else wants to build you're doing it
you're playing battlefield showing off
the new systems you know yeah of course
look at your rank enough you're doing
you're doing some work you know if only
I could build this fast in fortnight I'd
be a god
what if they added that speed just which
building in valve bill Oh take a wait do
we have you I can't tell from this like
oh yeah we do you guys having fun
watching building simulator I am the
same fortnight no it's not how many
points I need for the v1 rocket what's
that button two for to check
[Laughter]
hold Q nope that's prom xxxx don't give
it to hold X G you're building a whole
new brand Eric a whole new privilege oh
not cool dude I'm trying to build here
oh that's a challenge Kiefer just
dropped a challenge what do you kill
someone with a hammer really can't even
do that
if you do that I'll buy you lunch oh
damn this is gonna be a painful stream
though I don't even know if you can
can't even you can't I can't swing it
that's impossible no lunch
I regret this cuz that guys coming up
the hill Utah
dude are we like rolling these guys yeah
kind of
will they're taking Dido there blow you
oh well they're coming behind you oh
they're everywhere squirm you're okay
aren't iid though yeah they have more
people at D oh right below you turn
around I won't tell you what to do nice
good run I really wanted to be able to
like loop around because there's a
couple guys that we could have got there
see all that building I can't use the
hammer I literally tried MVP oh shoot I
might have wanted to spawn on that guy
oh he's at a sniped nice shot nice shot
now Shay he's dead I was trying to cue
the flag here but I guess it didn't
really matter
it's that bad guy looks like it huh my
bridge I was building that bridge you
were oh my god I gotta walk all the way
over there just spots fun on trash panda
dude we need to get be who's with me
nobody don't worry I'll get it back just
kidding there's two of them waiting for
me already you can always use the tools
it's hammer time
I literally was trying to swing the
hammer that's not how it works I don't
know man I think there's someone else on
the others I could kill the repair kit
there's someone else on the other team
who's doing more building than you think
so yeah it looks like
come on we gotta get Baker I didn't
build that bridge for the enemies to
have it
nice the guy right in front of me
just in time look all this work you've
done
Oh scheisse dude my squad isn't even
listening to their squad leader I said
take Baker they're like all the way up
at I can't even see how far up there
they're like up somewhere else
Oh squad spawn Co P knows what to do
mm-hmm I didn't build this this base for
nothing
good job
great work let's go for Delta space
economy communists ass if we think
there's gonna be a German campaign we
don't know I mean there wasn't anything
like that in battlefield 1 it was just
from the I mean I'm not they called it
Allies in World War 1 but you didn't you
never saw the Axis powers represented in
campaign as far as their perspective but
maybe here
dude we lost B again LZ oh there's
definitely a guy they're trying to use
my fortifications I built that not in
this house
not in this hand on this bridge no
please don't get shot in the back please
don't get shot in the back oh look my
squads finally here
look they heard you were building what's
up all right they heard a building so
they want to come see Oh what are you
damn it okay how's that Delta doing do
we lose that you're about to yeah go low
get ready weird that I can't Naidu you
think so Oh phantom news there's guys
there I came and see where it went okay
yep scared them
new dog was my fault I shouldn't have
been reloading see that's a really bad
habit it's like if you have 20 bullets
you should have enough confidence that
you don't need the whole clip to kill
somebody
and I don't have that confidence ooh
Kiefer mentioning Omaha Beach and Return
to Castle Wolfenstein I love that game
yes I don't think there's oh he didn't
mention Omaha Beach they kind of used it
as like as a point where they weren't
trying to focus on the more popular
battles of World War two they were
trying to tell like we need to figure
out how to shoot the rocket or whatever
you got it just take the time it's it's
B try holding B it's one of those BB C
there it is how many points do I need
though oh I only have 10,000 really yeah
where we've got a ways to go yes just
remind me later
well was it B is that what we did I
don't see okay
should I keep building very questioning
you know nameless is that not your name
Kiefer Sutherland oh there's two
Kieffer's oh really
that's crazy this is awkward
guy rocketing
how I'm literally here at dog gadem
where is this jerk at D
he's in he's probably gonna oh god it's
probably in the in the bridge think so
I'm gonna die anyway medic
you're a medic come here hey what's your
left your left mathematic are you faster
this guy too right dude I could really
sir
drop some health do your job
do you not see that I'm red no thank you
go oh yeah yeah yeah okay good now
you're back in it to win it
it's one shot okay he killed him but
then he died to someone else
I saw names damn this isn't cod good run
you can't just jump shot you can't jump
shot man you just can't that's not how
this game works
oh is it see I can't see the thing
well I'm reviving I'm terrible at our
names
no he's just tremble at her names how
tremble
how are we doing how are we doing on the
map here okay we got it's a it's even
three three no no sloppy noodle son
you're not getting a potato stop asking
that guy jumped a far distance
dude it's weird
um gun isn't shooting automatic anymore
like full auto your oh maybe you turned
the fire rate or JD do that oh nice
maybe thank you you were basically yeah
you attest uh fresh V you weren't
messing with huh yeah I was on single
shot there for a while and then I had to
adjust for it but that's fine
let's do you think we shot we support
him let's push him
back to full auto son I don't care what
you meant there are leftovers in the
fridge
yeah
oh it's a grenade I can't make you that
like as a thing to attack Q like I'm a
squad leader why can't I tell him to
assault this point you have to look I
don't know actually
is that the right flag yeah I guess it
is what happened to him that's what
happened oh yeah he stabbed him Oh
uppercut it oh he might say right so odd
guy squad guy save us squad
I'm right here trash Panda you're a
medic for Christ's sakes thank you God
yeah yeah that's why we have squads
I am fixed how can we build some more
all right how are we doing we had I
don't know if they ran out of milk did
you check the fridge great comic Oh
oh there's two of them and I choked it
should have just went on full auto and
sprayed it damn dude what no booze is
the guy that's carrying the teen 23 and
10 man
squads want oh I'm gonna get that guy
hopefully no not cuz the guy matured or
he's posted up with a brand that's smart
I'm surprised nobody's flanked that guy
yet don't do it
okay good I was like oh I want that guy
I want that guy real bad please don't
die Opie
he's enough using a good spot alright
there's two guys we got rap he's still
there he's still there is he in that
room all right
yeah let's let's oh gosh we lost all of
that pushing up too hard
okay how don't to it
it is the 80s different now it's the
same oh it's time to like gunfire do we
dare all right
they'll never know what hit them
nope that's other side ladders are hard
men that can be L got it
we should go throughout your little fort
there it is there's a good squad leader
we've got to capture that objective dog
all right we got bottle cuteness joining
the squad
[Music]
we're just at Baker no more no more no
more don't mind me you guys
[Music]
there are cosmetic loadouts we've yet to
see them though cuz this is just a
closed alpha for PC
they flank our guy that be resigned BC I
don't know why he's mentioning that our
scenes are always stuttering for him um
yeah I mean I don't know I don't see
anything CPU usage go up so I mean I
know I did
up the framerate though so you might
want to like go down a setting if your
internet might not be able to handle it
right
hello that my team will take it although
maybe I should let him revive and then
kill them both
you think that's a better tactic to do
what to like let him revive the guy and
then kill them both
mm-hmm I don't know I feel like I think
it's risky I think in this game like you
got a jump on those kills yeah we're not
skilled enough to
got him foggy hat I like your style
I throw random grenade - so you're like
I'm the semi on this right I switch back
and forth it's good for like when I'm
shooting a distance but then I feel like
when I'm up close I want to have that
like that cool mantle stick mantling
right there badass that's a close game
though how's our Howser know oh we're a
thousand away from the the v1 or a ten
thousand sorry you got some time dude
hit that other guy - yeah let's kill
that guy - mmm they're taking dog and
out though which is a problem
man don't make me turn this stream
around I didn't mean people are acting
real dumb the chat oh are they sick sick
sick sick sick sick I don't want to take
F anymore I want to take B
do we have crime says just capture
points and get that v2 I'm working on it
always working on it trying to get to
dog
for life and a dream no dream dreams
dead where was that guy you're doing
good you're almost there
yeah we have time though I mean we have
300 300 right now so pretty sure I'm
gonna get the rocket I don't know if I'm
gonna land it though son if there's no
milk in the fridge take some money on
top of the fridge the savings we have
and go run down the market and get
yourself some - we're playing as 1080p
because we're only stream @ 1080p yeah
play as a female next match I think
we're calling after this this one right
we are and I don't think that's an
option yet because there's no
customisation
it's not yeah we're playing on PC
okay there's at least two of them and I
just switched off auto if I had auto I
think he would have been dead yeah you
have got one for sure
dog I said could go to dog can I get a
kid can't we God is going do that guys
doing nothing thanks he was like over
there you know he's like practicing the
planes are so underpowered Baker were
literally right here smoke it's great to
hear Kiefer thank you Kiefer bars sorry
I'm on Baker my son is in the chat you
know if it's half past eight then
there's no milk tonight I'm sorry
we got shot don't drink my buddy get
yourself some water
dude he's flanked you thank you now
revive me hey I don't know why I even
bothered that just slows out my bleeding
yeah right
oh no I don't want spot on this guy this
this guy is just like a lone wolf he's
not doing any objectives though
ladders dangerous things those those
ladders are yeah that is what is one of
the riskiest things you can do in this
map is climb that ladder can't run up a
hill
apparently alright great work you have
gotten me four times that one guy I
don't even know how he's getting back
there to me maybe he's got a
nice maybe he's got a teammate sniping
or somewhere maybe it's pretty smart
though if that's their spot
Oh drink
oh great play by that guy great play I
was tucked himself away and peeked in
good good caught though good shot call
in there like it respect he's dead
though yeah he's dead
nope definitely not on you oh wait
oh he's dead now well trust tracks if
you're bored you can watch something
else or play alright maybe he doesn't
have a game though oh dude they're all
there let's go let's go come on give me
back in the fray wait how do I get back
downstairs oh dude you're close to the V
to everywhere am i close
yeah you're close Oh get me to be its
4141 what do you want
Zerg in the bridge hard yeah no [ __ ] why
are you guys all the way over there oh
no we're just getting destroyed now what
am i at 36 ie
oh that like falling on it yeah you're
kind of tripping there damn it
keep going well you guys consider
streaming dead cells we actually did
that slappy noodle we have
to get him please
thank you oh okay it wasn't worth it
wasn't worth I see I can't squat spawn
on you take objective Bravo
that lens flare that son here's so much
gunfire
hahaha
we just want the v1 rocket dude I need a
lot of points to get it no no actually I
was like what five hundred votes like
it's not impossible I just had to
what's layout or build out of my mind oh
no I think you should try capping points
I trying to go to a joke and man it's
cuz I'm - I'm like - uh like I know I
need to get the points and I'm like
Russian now yeah it's not good and we're
getting like stomps now cuz like oh man
whose great game bite you
I'm so sorry that oh yeah here we go
here we go yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah this
is why a squad spawn nice what just
happened to that what we got out there
done all right we got thing oh I'm at
40,000 all man you're close dude maybe I
can build a baker you think there's
anything to build
I don't think so dude it's not looking
good
oh I'm not even close I need a thousand
it's going up you're going up man oh
where do i where do I call it a tongue I
don't know anywhere f hell yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
all right look look for it look for it
it should come straight ahead I think I
know it's actually probably gonna come
from our side right it's not that come
on fly in already
we have 17 tickets tickets oh oh it
stopped nope oh it's above you yeah
there it is yeah we got nobody should
dropped it on B you got it that's cool
was it the wrong you got it amen
you got it
and a kill Oh in a second
haha you won't get to kill me mm-hmm
nice work
dang it at least at least we got to see
it flying I could've him it could have
been worse yeah I was surprised you like
it was weird how quickly it jumped I
don't know why that was happening I know
like maybe I do
yeah the points we're going up maybe my
squad doing stuff too yeah I'll be there
capturing a point maybe that yeah yeah
that's fun though
all right should we call it yeah I think
so
that was battlefield closed alpha 2 look
out look forward to babe maybe September
someone with said September sounds about
right
we were able to get access because we
got code last time when the Alpha was
out so now that the Alpha is back again
like Auto invited us it's only on PC
right now though so yeah stay tuned
again swap for more battlefield 5
coverage and then of course the rest of
the week
GameSpot live will be live at 11:00 a.m.
our normal time tomorrow probably
checking out some desks gambit 2d kind
of Dark Souls II platformer game and
then also Thursday think we're gonna
check out Xbox games with gold with Sam
and then also grave hoppers chi-chan
Mary we'll be back for another week with
Rob and Rob will continue his master
mode adventure we'll see how he goes
maybe some more book oblems will chase
yeah maybe
Gary be tough to death and Friday we'll
have our community game with the John
Luke and Ben but you got anything else
going on that we need up
no Gamescom got some getting some
coverage next week yeah that's about it
that's up button or as most youtubers
would say smash that sub button I feel
real bad about myself
let's take us out number two
take us out thank you guys
[Music]